[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il paraît qu'on a tous un vice une
petite faiblesse un péché mignon
j'en avais à vous faire moi mon fils
c'est le sport je cours je roule je suis
pas gay des heures parfois des journées
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas si
dérangeant que ça le sport mon fils
c'est plutôt positif et n'a peut-être
même certains qui aimeraient la voir se
visse voulait sortir du canapé le
dimanche voulant faire part de leurs
excès de la veille
c'est pas faux c'est plutôt positif mais
j'ai moi ça a pris quelques travers j'ai
toujours fait du sport en loisir qu'en
compétition
et puis j'ai découvert le raid
multisports c'est un enchaînement de
plusieurs sections de vtt canoë course à
pied par équipe en orientation le plus
souvent en autonomie sur plusieurs
heures voire plusieurs jours ça va
beaucoup plus alors je me suis entraîné
de plus en plus j'ai rencontré de plus
en plus de monde dans le milieu je me
suis documenté de plus en plus alors
j'ai voulu en faire encore plus et puis
d'encore plus dur et puis d'encore plus
long ce qui est génial c'est qu'il ya
toujours plus et puis je me suis blessé
alors je vais aller voir en kiné qui m'a
dit d'arrêter le sport n'était pas
question que j'arrête le sport pour ça
alors j'ai continué malgré la douleur
puis je suis allé voir un deuxième qui
n'est bon j'arrête et toujours pas le
sport mais ça va je le courrai plus je
faisais du vélo du canoë des lipstick la
natation alors que je déteste ça mais je
courrai plus bon il ya bien un moment
donné où il va lui fallu que je lève
franchement de pied et là je me senti
triste mort aux bons à rien évitable
avec tout le monde je me suis dit emilie
c'est quand même pas en train de nous
faire un syndrome dépressif
ah oui j'ai oublié de vous dire je suis
psychiatre
alors j'ai fouillé dans mes tiroirs et
puis j'ai ressorti cette guérilla je
faisais bien du sport au moins une fois
par jour
mon sport c'était mon activité favorite
celle que j'ai investi c'est plus que
tout autre
j'avais augmenter ma pratique au fur et
à mesure d'année en année dans la durée
aussi bien que non intensité j'étais
triste quand j'ai arrêté et ça allait
mieux quand je reprenais j'avais des
besoins compulsif de sport et gare à
celui qui passait la soirée avec moi si
j'avais pas pu caler ma séance
et même après un un arrêt ses besoins il
revenait très rapidement j'avais
continué à faire du sport malgré mes
difficultés de santé
négligeant les avis médicaux et j'avais
continué de faire du sport malgré mes
conflit avec mon compagnon
et puis c'est vrai que je masse très
niais à un simple gimont pour performer
encore plus alors j'ai réfléchi combien
de soirée j'avais loupé avec mes potes
parce qu'ils étaient plus disponible à
22h30 après mes entraînements qui était
devenu moments intimes de conversation
du quotidien nos petites soirées en
amoureux
j'étais en colocation avec mon compagnon
il est sa vie de son côté
il avait bien raison je revenais chaque
soir plus tard de mes entraînements sans
avoir prévenu par oubli prises dans
l'engouement de l'effort ou de porte mon
lev ces moments là ouais y avait un
souci toutes les cages étaient costauds
étaient couchés mais j'étais pas un
syndrome dépressif
j'étais en sevrage j'étais addict ou
sport alors je me suis dit en même temps
elle est peut-être mieux que je tombe
sur une paire de baskets que sur un rail
de coke
vous allez me dire ça n'a rien à voir
ben si parce que finalement toutes les
dépendances elle fonctionne à peu près
de la même manière sur un plan
neurobiologiques c'est le circuit la
récompense qui déraille circulent à
récompenser celui qui régule la faim la
soif la sexualité c'est ce qui a poussé
les espèces à continuer à manger boire
et procréer et ce qui fait que on est
encore là aujourd'hui le coeur de
circuit c'est la dopamine
en gros vous avez faim vous mangez la
dopamine augmente ça vous soulage ça
vous fait plaisir c'est la récompense
j'ai appris il ya plein de zones
cérébrales qui vont réguler ce système
il ya une zone qui va faire
l'apprentissage de ce système vous avez
appris quand vous avez faim il faut
manger pour être soulagé il ya une autre
zone qui va coûter pour la valeur de la
récompense c'est combien il va vous
faire plaisir ce plat qui vous attend
dans le frigo
il y en a une autre qui va côté pour
l'émotion qui associés et qui est
approprié
ça vous rend heureux démange et un carré
de chocolat mais vous n'avez pas crié de
joie à chaque fois quoique
et puis il y en a une autre qui va faire
la balance décisionnelle c est ce que ça
vaut le coup je me lève de mon canapé
pour aller chercher ce plat dans le
frigo est ce qu'il n'est pas trop loin
est ce que j'ai à ses fins est-ce que
c'est raisonnable parce que c'est pas
trop dangereux l'accident domestique ça
existe bref les drogues elles elles vont
augmenter artificiellement la dopamine
ce qui fait que le signal envoyé au
cerveau il va être très puissant et la
valeur récompense surévaluée c'est waou
et cette cigarette magique elle me donne
trop de plaisir
du coup l'émotion elle est associée ça
me rend très heureux ça donne envie de
prendre et de rien mais du coup les
capacités décisionnelles elles sont
complètement altérée
j'en veux tout le temps et on arrive à
des comportements compulsifs
à plus long terme le cerveau il va
pallier à l'augmentation de dopamine en
augmentant le nombre de récepteurs
mais ce qui fait que quand tu auras
moins de dopamine parce que moins de
produits ou moins de comportements
il va se retrouver rapidement au sevrage
après il y trouve une deuxième solution
il diminue la sensibilité des récepteurs
mais du coup il faudra plus de produits
plus de comportements plus de dopamine
pouvoir accéder à la même dose de
plaisir
alors ça c'est sur un plan
neurobiologiques mais sur un plan plus
global
en pratique la diction c'est la
rencontre d'un individu avec un produit
dans un environnement un contexte
particulier bah oui la grand mère qui
dans sa maison de retraite tombe sur un
petit sachet de but c'est déjà peu
probable elle aura déjà bien du mal si
tant est qu'elle sèche ce que ces termes
ma foi bien odorantes à se rouler sont
joints alors de là à en devenir
dépendantes
on en est loin alors qu'est ce qui
s'était passé pour moi on reprend le
produit c'est le sport pourquoi il va
donner du plaisir
déjà sur plan biologique il va créer des
endorphines qui est la molécule
florissante qui soulage la douleur
il va créer de l'adrénaline la molécule
les sensations fortes du stress c'est le
succès des manèges à sensations il va
augmenter progressivement la sérotonine
qui régule l'humeur de manière positive
et puis enfin
il va jouer lui même sur la dopamine
cette fameuse hormone du plaisir et la
récompense
à côté de ça c'est quelque chose de il a
plein de propriété positifs notamment
sur le point de la santé on connaît tous
sa ça améliore les capacités cardiaques
respiratoires musculaires ça renforce
les os c'est réguler la prise de poids
ça diminue le stress et puis on peut le
voir aussi par ses rituels
d'entraînement ces règles comme
l'apprentissage de la ténacité la
discipline et donc de la performance
si je vous dis tout ça c'est que dans
notre société actuelle l'environnement
en général
c'est très important les culte de la
performance et de la parents sont
omniprésents actuellement on nous
demande pour réussir d'être performant
c'est plus facile d'être intégrés si on
correspond à l'image idéale il faut être
beau il faut être fort il faut être
musclé il faut être mince fait en bonne
santé et donc le sport y colle tout à
fait assez de culte mais ça suffit pas
on n'est pas tous dépendants au sport
dans notre société
alors il ya l'environnement proche aussi
qui joue la famille les amis
mes parents n'étaient pas de grands
sportifs ils m'ont toujours donné accès
au sport ils m'ont emmené tous les ans
dans des clubs de sport ils m'ont appris
à la montagne à skier à randonner et
puis j'avais un modèle chez moi ma
grande soeur elle adorait le sport est
devenu prof de sport et donc j'ai garé
créer chez moi autour de moi sans me
rendre compte un réseau social amical en
lien avec le sport et puis après une
question de vulnérabilité chaque
individu est plus ou moins vulnérables
ma grande soeur qui a vécu dans le même
milieu que moi et qui adorent et le
sport n'en est pas pour autant
dépendantes
alors c'est le moment de parler de moi
parce que pour le coup la personne
vulnérable ça est témoin alors c'est pas
un exercice facile de parler soir en
public surtout quand on n'a pas
confiance en soi alors je vous vois
venir
elle dit qu'elle n'a pas confiance en
elle et elle fait un tas dicks bah oui
parce que ce complexe d'infériorité jeu
le compense jeu sûr qu'on pense aux
blancs sont des défis et petit challenge
c'est pour ça que je suis venu
incapable de résister ou challenge et à
l'expérience nouvelle alors le défi
c'est pour prouver ce que je vous à moi
même déjà et puis aux autres c'est
important le regard des autres quand on
n'a pas confiance en soi puis une fois
que tu parti faut que j'aille jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au boutiste perfectionniste
c'est un trait de caractère qu'on
retrouve beaucoup chez les personnes
addictes aux sports et puis l'expérience
nouvelle c'est pour tester mes limites
chercher de nouvelles expériences des
nouvelles sensations la recherche de
nouvelles sensations c'est aussi quelque
chose qu'on retrouve beaucoup chez les
personnes dépendantes en général quand
on est pas persuadé de sa valeur on sent
perdue dans la masse et c'est difficile
d'éprouver la sensation d'exister alors
je vais la chercher autrement dans la
gestion du risque dans la douleur
physique la douleur mentale dans la
sensation d'être différente des autres
ce qui m'empêche pas pour autant de
vouloir malgré moi nous conformer à
l'image idéale société toujours une
question de réassurance et de regard des
autres alors le sport il remplit tout le
cahier des charges
il me permet de me lancer des défis par
son côté compétition il me permet de
trouver nouvelles sensations par son
côté extrême
il me rassure par rapport à l'image que
j'ai de moi et de ma forme physique
alors la fin de la consultation avec moi
même je me suis dit voilà emilie tu es
une personne avec une personnalité à
risque de dépendance aux sports qui a eu
accès facilement aux sports et qui s'est
laissé influencer par l'environnement la
société dans laquelle elle vit ça donne
une toxico 10 sport c'est comme si
j'avais trouvé mon petit shoot un bon
cocktail de dopamine d'adrénaline et
d'endorphines que j'ai envie de me faire
encore et encore alors comme à toute
bonne toxiques aux jeux mais aussi
prescrit une petite thérapie
puis quand je suis super psychiatre ça
va beaucoup mieux alors attention j'ai
pas dit que j'étais complètement guéri
je continue à faire du sport de manière
intensive tous les jours je vais encore
inscrit à des compétitions que certains
qualifient de débile mais j'ai trouvé un
certain équilibre
l'addiction c'est pas comme on dit
souvent une question de volonté
je pense que si j'avais pas de volonté
je serais bien en peine de grimper mais
si 1000 mètres de dénivelé positif sur
mais sans borne
mais c'est une erreur de motivation les
capacités décisionnelles sont altérées
l'a vu tout à l'heure alors le tout
c'est de reprendre conscience de ses
propres motivations et de pondérer sa
vie en fonction il ya un exercice que
j'aime bien faire avec mes passions je
leur demande de côté sur une échelle de
1 à 10
leur valeur c'est à dire les choses et
les personnes importantes pour eux puis
leur demande de côté sur cette même
échelle
le temps passé pour chacune de ces
valeurs si une différence entre ces deux
chiffres
c'est qu'il ya un souci parmi mes
valeurs à moi il y avait mon bien-être
physique et mental
mais il y avait aussi ma famille alors
pour le coup je vais essayer chanceuse
d'être tombé sur cette dépendance parce
que le sport en plus d'être légal il
m'apporte quelque chose en termes de
bien-être
et puis même avec ma famille dans le
partage alors l'idée sap a été de
l'arrêter mais de réorganiser ma vie de
faire des compromis avec des choses un
peu moins importante mais finalement
j'ai appris que les compromis quand on
sait pourquoi on les fait ça vous coûte
beaucoup moins et on nous le rend bien
avant je stressais à chaque fois que je
partais en entraînement de peur que ma
famille m'en veuille
et puis je stresse et à chaque fois que
j'étais avec ma famille de pas pouvoir
caler ma séance d'entraînement à présent
je n'arrive à profiter pleinement de
l'instant présent qui vous me croirez ou
non mais mon mari
le colloque il m'encourage maintenant
même à faire ce que je fais avec une
certaine fierté qui nous rend moi même
fier quelles sont vos valeurs
les choses et les personnes importantes
pour vous qu'est-ce qui vous guide et
vous fait vibrer dans votre vie une fois
que vous aurez répondu à ces questions
vous saurez où et à quelle dose y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]